la police coloniale des loges avec
violence et mépris cette barricade
d'autres surgiront tant que trudeau
refusera d'écouter les chefs
traditionnels tant que la grc occuperont
les territoires waits whitten tant que
ce pathétique projet de pipeline ne sera
pas annulé l'état colonial canadien
serait totalement paralysé ça c'est la
déclaration des manifestants à saint
lambert hier avant de plier bagage et de
lever leur blocage donc sur la voie
ferrée le député caquistes et adjoint
parlementaire de la ministre de la
sécurité publique
ian lafrenière est avec nous ce matin
chez la première bonjour bonjour bon
moteur
bonjour donc le blocage a été levé sans
intervention policière qu'est ce qui a
permis de convaincre les manifestants de
partir sans l'intervention policière
avec un travail policier et ça c'est ce
qu'on veut souligner ce matin on veut
les remercions veux les féliciter pour
ce qu'ils ont fait c'était de la
négociation de la médiation
on a donné un échéancier qui était très
clair c'est ce qui a fait en sorte que
ya 22 heures les gens ont quitté et on
aurait pu aller de force les faire
quitter et se dit à quel moment ils vont
venir où ils vont venir ce qu'on va
pousser
est-ce qu'on vous positionner des
policiers tout le long d'une voie ferrée
c'est vraiment impossible à penser et la
stratégie appartient la police mais je
voudrais que ça ressemble drôlement ce
qu'on avait vécu à occupons montréal
donc plusieurs villes dans le monde qui
a décidé d'utiliser la force morale
avait utilisé la médiation ça fait en
sorte qu'on a réglé une crise une crise
pour de bon dans cependant on le règle
et hier mais j'entendais les propos du
premier ministre canadien
je se rappeler que le québec une partie
de responsabilté plomb et l'on se défile
pas on réglera au port le conflit le
complice d'un conflit pour le fédéral
devrait glisser les premières nations
hier après deux semaines de s'avère
finalement que les provinces le reg
avoue que c'est un petit peu insultant
avec nous on est là on fait notre
travail mais ça prend ça pour une
coordination vraiment fédéral c'est à
dire que vient de province de tchimou
plusieurs provinces au pays regroupent
au sud seul le second essai pour vous
revenons à ce blocage la qui a été levée
à saint-lambert faut quand même
mentionné que ce n'était pas des
manifestants autochtones ce n'était pas
non plus un territoire autochtone mais
il y en a d'autres au québec on pense en
gaspésie on pense à l'isle-verte je
pense que ça a été le seul terminal chez
l'humain
vous amenez le bon pour connaître oui
pour la présence des gens la provenance
d'égypte de surplace l'encollage vous
sentez des vieilles histoires de police
pour moi mais dans les finales l'arc et
du canadien quand on fait des
arrestations
cent pour cent des gens qu'on avait
arrêté n'avait même pas vu le match ce
que je voudrais c'est qui est ce qu'on
peut se poser la question est ce que ce
sont des gens qui ont profité de
l'événement un but l'occasion envoyé à
l'ensemble des gens qui sont masquées tu
va l'envoyer message mais qui se masque
particulier et je le remercie les
citoyens aussi content et très patient
pas j'ai vu des gens se dirigeaient sur
le périmètre passer leur mécontentement
motivé aussi je voudrais comme ancien
policier nous chercher en long une
cohabitation sociale c'est important
c'était important que ça c'est ce blocus
là que les citoyens peuvent plus
reprendre le train de banlieue le dis
parce qu'au final on ne parle
d'environnement mon blog un train de
banlieue je vais revenir quand même aux
autres blocages
lorsque bon aussi ce sont davantage les
manifestants des manifestants
autochtones en appui avec les what you
et n en colombie britannique
françois legault dit cette semaine il
faut faire lever les barricades même a
dit qu'il faudrait faire appel à la
police
vous en pensez quoi vous comment ces
policiers moi je vous dis que ça prend
une stratégie et vous avez vu on se
défie le pouilleux une intervention ça
fonctionnait mais je vous dis encore une
fois est-ce que la police va tout régler
ce que le fait de déplacer ces gens là
ça fera pas en sorte qu'ils vont se
réinstaller le lendemain alors là quand
je vous parle de coordination et de la
police c'est une partie de la solution
c'est vrai mais ça prend la négociation
s'apprend gouvernement fédéral qui se
dit écoutez je prends mes
responsabilités on va s'asseoir ensemble
autour d'une solution ce qui est délicat
c'est que nous réglerons puis nous quand
je nous les gens du terrain ne règleront
riez est-ce qu'on va déplacer le
problème pour plus tard et pour personne
qui veut vivre avec ce stress de se dire
d'une journée à l'autre ils vont se
réinstaller alors oui la police est une
solution il faut vraiment négocier pour
rencontrer les gens de programmation le
malaise y ait là je suis à la presse
mais nous auriez doit poursuivre avec
cette main tendue qui ne donne rien
concrètement je le redis devrait
commencer commencé en disant aux
profanations je suis prêt à vous
rencontrer il faut trouver une solution
il ya du travail terrain de soir en même
temps mais de penser que la province
soit réglée sur tout seul si l'on en
pense et ça peut être frustrant pour
nous très bien merci beaucoup merci bien